let's talk about some of this uh this
environmental disaster stuff we got
going on so you know obviously
we've been talking about um what you can
invest in the cost of lumber the cost of
food the inflation
right now in california they're dealing
with a mega drought
uh the verge reports the hoover dam
reservoir is at an
all-time low and apparently they're
putting
in in california they're under some kind
of uh
rationing for water yeah the water man
how does it work
i'm going to be careful with how i put
this
so i don't present myself as a water
expert but
my reporting on congressman devin nunes
he's in central
california and you know he represents a
big ag district
22nd district in in california
and he was originally elected to fight
the water wars and so i know a little
bit
about the central uh the central valley
water
issues and one of the cases these guys
make and it's pretty convincing to me is
there's an awful lot of water coming off
the sierra nevada
uh and this is what makes the central
valley so
fertile so rich what they they call the
bread basket of the solar system
some of this the water wars what the
water wars are about
it's about environmentalists or people
who describe themselves as
environmentalists
in the bay area to a lesser extent los
angeles
and a lot of this in effect what they're
doing again and i'm not i'm not i don't
know
what's happening at the hoover dam i
just want to give a little background on
what i know about the water wars out in
california
they say there's an awful lot of water
in california
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to break
they're trying to break their political
opponents
the game is with the left what they're
trying to do is
they're trying to hurt their economic
base strip them of their economic base
in the central valley the agricultural
base and also push them into the cities
where they can control them so again but
by what by blocking water or what
yeah they run a lot of the water off
into the bay and it's an argument about
the uh
the smelts and what people say about the
smelt is like this
you know nothing against the smell
yeah the delta smells right you know
about you know about this right
so the delta smelts are also a bait fish
for i believe it's a trout
that's an imported fish right the trout
they brought the trout out there
it's an imported fish and and the smelts
the smelts are eaten by the trout so
what their point is is that the
environmentalist argument
isn't very uh it's doesn't have a lot of
integrity
so they're entirely honest this is a uh
in
in my research when i covered the the
last drought in the past you know
six seven six or so years i would say
that you're about half
like what you're saying is about half of
uh what's right where to put this
in my research it half agrees with what
you're saying
um in places like tulare county they're
barred from using surface water for
for uh growing crops because it's
diverted to the cities
and it's a really simple thing it's one
of the biggest arguments i have for the
electoral college
you have this one state with no
electoral system no no proportional
representation
what happens is the farmers in these
counties make about 300 000 people but a
large portion of the economy
over in san diego and la they have tens
of millions of people
so then they all say hey we're going to
vote on who gets the water from the poor
people
yeah and so when you get 300 000 farmers
and poor people
and then you get ten tens of millions of
city people right and they say now
everybody vote
well that's what ben franklin said a
well-armed uh
a democracy is two wolves in a lamb
deciding what's for lunch
a republic is a well-armed lamb
contesting the vote so
what we end up seeing is the farmers had
to drill
thousands upon thousands of feet into
the earth for groundwater
but the poor people who lived in um
east east porterville i think it was
called their their wells only went 30
feet so they went dry
they had no water left in their homes
taken by the farmers
because the farmers were in a drought
and there were canals with surface water
and i said
there's so much water there can't you
take it and they were like it's not
we're not legally allowed to
it's diverted to cities so the water
runoff from the mountains at a time of a
drought goes to the cities who say they
need it more
but i will i will mention one thing as
for the delta because so uh i went i
went to the bay area
and uh we talked to many people about
the the smelts and
what the farmers wanted to do was they
said we got a lot of this water up north
that goes into the bay and does nothing
it reaches
the the you know san francisco around
that area where it hits the ocean
and it basically makes all that fresh
water useless we should divert that
fresh water
have it go around the bay and go to the
farms
now the political argument was the smelt
oh but you're going to kill all these
fish if you do that
i think the more sound argument was we
actually i actually went to a bunch of
cities
in the bay area uh smaller cities not
san francisco not oakland
and i i went to a bunch of farms one of
the farms i went to was
i believe it was an apple farm it could
be wrong i did some kind of fruit and
they said the water that we get for this
farm
is it's bay area water so we're we got
all these you know tributaries streams
and whatever
it's all the delta water if you divert
that water
it will reduce pressure causing ocean
water to come in
killing all of the fresh water in the
bay and wiping out all the small towns
that rely on that water
so it may be that you could you know the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few
but they were like what about our family
farm that's been here for generations
for hundreds of years that would be
destroyed by salt water coming in and
wiping out our farms
it's tough one of the solutions for the
water problem was desalination
desalination but what that does is it
creates brine runoff that goes down to
the bottom of the ocean bed killing off
the lower lowest level of life
causing a dead zone from the ground up
when you wipe out the food chain yeah
you need to find a way to reuse that
salt if you're gonna do that for sure
yeah they
but they just dump it back into the
ocean and it's it's it's brine it sinks
and then kills all the all the you know
floor and fauna on the ocean floor then
everything above it dies
um this big goes back to this guy named
william mull holland you guys ever hear
this guy
they named the street after him yeah
mulholland drive in los angeles he was
it's 1913
the year the same year they made the
federal reserve the basis of chinatown
oh william holland so what he did was he
went up to this place
owens river the river valley and and
diverted all this is before l.a existed
it was a desert and he diverted
all this farmland water down south to
create the city
and that's why they named the street
after them in l.a they're built on a
desert it's not supposed to be there
they're importing the water and
stripping it from the rest of the state
they hit hard if colorado right now was
like hey california
no california's gone socal's gone their
water is gone
it's colorado river water yes it is yeah
colorado's got like a treaty or
something but they could just be like
nah
if imagine if a drought hit colorado
though if colorado for some reason was
facing you know did it happen yeah it
happens all the time
oh there you go quite regularly and then
colorado's like sorry you know colorado
first no water for you california
china's doing that they're like blocking
uh river water to other countries
because a lot of rivers
run off in chinese mountains i think
they did it themselves during the
olympics
you know several years ago all the poor
farmers were restricted what's going to
happen in california then what's going
to happen and uh
yeah what's going to happen in southern
california well i mean california as it
stands seems to be
post-apocalyptic yeah you know it's
funny i i hear from these people they're
like california is so nice
i'm sick and tired of people having zero
perspective
it's like bro if you are a frog in a pot
i don't want to hear your opinion i'm
kidding
you know we'll have an argument about it
but you need to like look at the pots
that are boiling because you're in
california
and people are like it's not so bad here
and i'm like how many times have you
seen like a homeless person take a dump
in the street
12 in the past month but what's the big
deal and i'm like it should be zero
when i lived there it was like one or
two once or twice a month
san francisco's got a patrol now the
last time i went to la
i parked my car and i was going to a
mall and some woman
some some old fat woman walked in the
middle of the street and just squatted
and went at it
and i'm
i've been in san francisco several times
it's a shame it's a shame it's a great
city
beautiful these were all great american
cities until someone decided they needed
to be burned down
well a whole bunch of people decided
they need to be destroyed it's it's
i think it's really simple it's a very
simple mathematic equation
if republican says be responsible and
democrat says
i'll give you free stuff it's a very
it's a slope
it is an uphill and a downhill and like
homer simpson
springfield has a westward slope so they
knew which direction he was going to
walk
it's so sad it's it's a great they're
great cities in a great state and a
great country
that is yeah it's drastically behind
schedule on developing desalination
tactics
we have so much fresh water we have so
much salt water access to so much salt
water being on
basically an island you know north
america united states it's not a
long-term solution
and desalination yeah and groundwater
isn't either because
there's um what is it called um
subsidation i think the word is i could
be wrong
uh could you look look that up yeah when
you pull the groundwater out
that water actually provides some kind
of structural support pressure
at a lower level it subsides yeah right
it's gonna be the words subsidization
oh no that's not it yes no that's
subsidies yeah uh subsidation
could be wrong but uh what happens is
when you pull the water out the ground
starts sinking
and that it's really bad so
i think that's the future for california
oh yeah
i think i think california is going to
get really bad maybe what they're trying
to do with this great reset stuff with
like new york is get rid of as many
people as possible so the cities can
survive
i hear people also saying that they want
to build these again speculation from
interested friends they say yeah they
want to build these kind of fancy
uh big asian style cities these kind of
showcase cities where you don't really
have many people living in them
yeah i couldn't uh find subsidence
subsidence
so what the groundwater is like is is a
buffer for other
to to keep other things from well when
you need to land
and to keep salt water out when they
pull the water out of the ground doesn't
matter where you are
like the ground like the the ground goes
down caves in yeah you know with
fracking
a lot of the fracking stuff is causing
earthquakes across the country and i
think it's because they're removing
liquid
from similar to this maybe and it's
causing the the ground to like fall and
shake
so i was thinking we could pump water
back into the earth to like make up for
the oil that we take out
and to re re-subsidize or whatever you
would call
subsidize ah people need to drink water
man
maybe maybe this look this is this is
all the great reset people they're like
we're drinking too much water we're
pulling too much
they're saying that too are you kidding
me they're saying we're drinking too
much water
oh yeah they're the reason they want to
ban beef is how much water we have to
use to
for the cows to drink that's insane i
think
i thought it was just their their whole
thing about cam
oh it's all climate change but bovine
flatulence i didn't know what i had
anything to do with yeah it's
with water as well like thousands of
gallons they say
of water per cow for like a meat product
and it's wasteful
almonds almonds take a lot of water to
produce
so it's very it's like we're gonna see
almond prices start skyrocketing because
of the drought in california it's gonna
be bad
uh avocados as well california produces
what like
how much of the food of the world like a
massive say like one fish yes
yeah and california is being propped up
by farmers
who are producing for their gdp and if
they leave then the state
is they're in trouble right if they turn
it into wind farms then i guess
we will be eating bugs pretty soon
that's why uh i
as well as many other people like jack
bosobic have been saying get out of
cities you don't want to be in a city
i mean it's almost like they fired a
shot across the bow last year with the
lockdowns and the riots
get out of the cities they were they
were basically forcing you to do it oh
absolutely absolutely
right i mean so if you have if you
have the ability to not leave these
places that are increasingly dangerous
and increasingly spiritually
uh bleak yeah you you have to go
there's no choice we we were in the
philadelphia suburbs
and we decided to leave almost
immediately when the pandemic happened
so we actually had a conversation
about there was there was talks about
quarantining states
no joke they were like shutting down
bridges right away too yeah and so we
were like
why almost immediately what did you guys
see right away that made you
oh yes i mean no no it was the state
came out and said
we will lock down the bridges and
quarantine the state
okay it coincided with expanding the
business too so i had been thinking
about just getting a larger
we were going to buy tim was going to
buy like a big office in jersey but
obviously covet struck and that was kind
of off the table it was already
you were finding challenges with that
yeah everything everything shut down wow
it just made it possible to do anything
and so
we ended up just sitting inside and
doing
this show and one iteration of it for
months because
you couldn't do anything and so i was
just like one of one of the problems we
had was you go to you go to walmart
nothing there it was like we go to the
store and there's like there's a photo
on my instagram of my friend adam and
it's just like there's no toilet paper
anywhere
just all gone i'm i'm not i mean weirdly
i'm not a
it's an old it's an old thing in
american history right i mean kind of
our resources
are our myths about uh cincinnatus the
citizen farmer who comes and fights
yeah i mean but it is also it is also
about
that's our origins these are the stories
that we tell about america
and write the city from the bible on
from the bible
from the bible to the present it's
always been a place
of crime and corruption and pestilence
and that's what it is again
i think that americans need to
reconnect to our roots and to reconnect
to things that aren't about politics
whether it's
family and community you know what that
sounds like an argument for the great
reset
but i but i would i would reset it
entirely differently
right you know what i'm saying i'm not
talking about resetting people having
americans having individual choice and
making a decision
i think people need to get out of cities
they should roll up their sleeves learn
how to chop some wood
learn how to grow their own food take
care of some chickens
get some you know fresh eggs nothing
beats you walk out in the yard in the
morning you eat a couple fresh eggs you
make them
right there on the spot and it's like
thank you chickens it's delicious not
these garbage store-bought trash
but but people are so reliant i mean the
people in the cities i think are the
biggest problem
the the rural conservatives aren't the
ones destroying the planet
the the the it's the these urban
liberals are the ones who come they
complain about everything they vote for
they vote for these these these
governors they vote for these mayors who
create the
police brutality they vote for these
conditions they live in these
hyper-concentrated
break particle dust in the air with gas
and all the exhaust they're breathing in
trash they're living in cities that
smell like sour milk
sour milk and cubicles crown on top of
each other they're the ones consuming
the most energy for this
this gluttonous lifestyle on average and
then the people in the countryside who
are voting republican live
you know sparsely populated areas where
they're
on like natural you know like they have
their own oil tank to manage their own
heat
they have you know satellite internet
much more lower cost they're doing solar
panels
much more self-reliant i i always
imagine that they knew this
though that it's not a lot of times we
think about in terms of hypocrisy i
think that actually that's part of how
they're establishing um their elite
status
right when we saw gavin newsom walking
around all the time without his mask
and there were a whole bunch of them
right through whitmer as well
uh pelosi pelosi who was the the mayor
of uh philadelphia
right he was also caught i think in new
jersey or somewhere
without his mask but a certain voucher
was caught with his mask exactly
so at a certain point it's like they're
not all making a blunder they know their
political figures they're being looked
at
it was part of to establish that they
are part of a higher class right
it's a hierarchy there at the top you
are on the bottom so when you talk about
the difference between
the people who are the elites who are in
cities and the
the people who are on farms that's the
point to say we're better than you we
can
we can spend this it's like the
celebrities who fly on private jets to
go pick up their awards for
environmentalism
they want you to suffer so they can keep
living in luxury
they mean to show you they want to rub
it in your face it's not like
what hypocrites leonardo dicaprio it's
like i know what i'm doing so
so what you're saying is eat the rich
yeah
okay no no solon would tell us otherwise
that's called that's called the kathy
newman that's her name right yeah so
what you're saying
would say otherwise yeah apparently it's
we're going to come to a head where
people are going to want you look at the
french revolution people are going to
want to hurt other people because of
greed or because of
um jealousy but we don't you know we
stay peaceful we work together as a team
we all want to come out of this better
and benefit together we can i got i got
my issues with elon musk
you know the bitcoin dogecoin the
pumping and dumping all that silly silly
nonsense
i can respect him for spacex and
starlink we're like trying to get
starlink
we actually got someone brought out a
starlink for us but they're cell locked
so it didn't work we need an actual
regional
unit so we weren't able to do it but
it'll be really awesome to have i guess
we'll just wait until we get it
uh so so that's cool like work on cool
stuff i'll tell you who
you know when i think about the phrase
eat the rich i don't know really know
what they mean by that like consume the
resources from them
you want to throw in hollywood i'll tell
you this leftists hear me out
let's start by eating the rich in
hollywood
yes and we all agree and we will start
there we'll start there
we'll probably have to compromise after
that but i think that's a good place to
to go because
you know like the rich chocolate cake
yeah
i'm saying like if if if you know i look
at wall street
and i look at hollywood and those are
two things where i'm like for the most
part
i'm not you can go the hedge funds that
are shorting companies into oblivion
these these these apes and the meme
stocks it's a revolution it's fantastic
they're basically they found they found
the weakness these shorts and they found
a way to stick it to the hedge funds
hopefully it works out we'll see what's
happening a lot of people have been
covering this and i'm excited to see it
work out
hollywood these are the hypocrites who
say we're going to save the planet
don't uh uh you know stop flying in
planes
oh my private jets here i gotta go and
they go live in their their 50-bedroom
mansion
those are two sectors of the economy i
got no problem with
regulating out of existence or just
you know figuratively eating the rich i
i find it heartbreaking i mean
the tech sector too sorry yeah mark
zuckerberg bye
i i find the hollywood stuff
heartbreaking though i mean because
before
right before covet 19 we used to go to
movie theaters remember that yeah i know
that's why i like amc stock yeah okay
that's that's in that's great
i can't go to movie theaters go to
dinner beforehand get a drink after
sit with your uh you know sit with your
beloved
uh go with a group of friends children's
birthday party now it's heartbreaking
now when they turn the lights back on in
hollywood you've got one of these
you've got some lunatic screaming at you
for being
uh for being white right exactly
it's ridiculous and look there's still a
lot of
terrific stuff they're doing but there's
a lot of garbage they're doing as well
but do you notice the people that don't
say anything
the people who are never out front on
the political stuff
how they come across no one ever knows
no one knows what al pacino thinks about
politics
right right you know now that i think
about it i'm like
is there is there a certain sector of
ultra wealthy individuals that we're
actually eager to defend anyway
like i can i can i can defend elon on
some things
is there i got no respect for bezos that
dude is nuking
everything he's burning to the ground
he's a he's a lunatic the
like and i'm talking about amazon
amazon's book burning i'm like these
people got too much power
zuckerberg's awful jack dorsey is awful
they're all just
so awful you know what i'm over it let's
set a threshold and get rid of you know
we'll eat the rich i'm there leftists
you got me i'm tired of these people
they're just awful they're destroying
everything it would be nice to be able
to find one
sector i mean you can't i mean
entertainment
i got nothing where but look look at
like a lower level
you've got media where they're not the
multi-billion dollar media you've got
like you've got wealthy conservatives
who do media and it's all right you get
wealthy liberals they do media it's all
right but then you look at the big
corporate machines
awful get out of here all of you are
gone yeah you look at you look at
technology
we got minds.com hey bill on me he's all
right he's a cool dude you got bit shoot
you got gab i'm okay with those things
you got
facebook nah get facebook out of there
you know too big
too big too bad it should be awful i
think the tech should speak for itself
mine's as cool because it's open source
free software so like it's
we spent all this time building it and
now you can have it
for free and use it now you can have
your own copy of it and spin up your own
social network for free
because it's all available that kind of
thing yeah it does if the ceo turns out
to be a multi-trillionaire
whatever the technology is amazing so
here's the other problem
all right if we if we agree that there
are a lot of really awful really wealthy
people that are screwing everything up
zuckerberg dumping money in his
elections
bezos uh you know he's doing the same
thing with amazon wokeness
you know pushing these ideologies then
you've got you know
big tech the problem is what you give
their money to the government
now the government's the same thing so
do we
eat the government figuratively what
does that mean
maybe maybe hold on maybe there's like a
little portion of the left and say eat
the rich and then the right when they
say small government and that's you got
to combine
i don't know how you do that centralized
what does that look like
bitcoin maybe decentralizing yeah the
tech sector is decentralizing like i was
working with the fedoverse team we're
building out the fetaverse which is this
like federated
system of free software technology where
like
all these different websites can
intercommunicate and
it's it's a big deal um i go more into
it in a little while
um we're decentralizing the the
entertainment industry hollywood is gone
vagina now you can we're doing this from
here in the middle of you know
the mountains of west virginia so that's
exciting yeah um the tech sector
now with bitcoin the tech sector is
decentralizing with cryptocurrency
finance uh politics is next um i'm
big into like apps that where we can
vote locally with app technology
and kind of control our own destiny from
loc local service guarantees citizenship
yes
i don't know what service means but i'm
into it any kind of service development
anything i'm i'm i'm committed to the
idea that we move
not move away from politics but that we
expand and i'm including
i'm not just saying people on the right
i'm just saying as americans
we ex expand past politics there's no
redemption in politics i guess you know
one of the big problems there's just
these stubborn people that stand in the
way of solving these problems
maybe what we need is for like an entity
of the people to rise up and seize power
maybe with weapons
and then instill their political
ideology by force
i'm kidding yeah yeah i see you've
studied history yeah
right that always works out thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you